are you happy with the format i'm very
happy ready for the first question yes
exactly here we go let's start with our
first question and that is diana who's
here on the front row good evening diana
what's your question for mr my question
for liz is the bank of england have said
that a recession is inevitable
what could you do to mitigate the impact
of this
well what the bank of england have said
today is of course extremely worrying
but it is not inevitable we can change
the outcome and we can make it more
likely that the economy grows
and what's important is first of all
that we need to help people struggling
with the cost of living i would
immediately reverse the national
insurance increase i would also have a
temporary moratorium on the green energy
level to save people money on fuel bills
but i'd also keep corporate corporation
tax low to make sure that we are
attracting investment into our economy
and doing all we can to avoid a
recession because i know what it's like
when people lose their jobs when towns
and cities across our country struggle i
don't want our country to go through
that that's why it's so important we
keep taxes low and we do all we can to
grow the economy by taking advantage of
our post-brexit freedom unleashing
investment changing things like the
procurement rules and doing things
differently but now is the time to be
bold because if we don't act now we are
headed for very very difficult times are
you happy with that i am that's good to
hear thank you okay anybody else going
to follow up on that one for us
nobody at this stage we're just warming
you up still aren't we okay well i've
got one you're confident that you'll be
able to avert a recession by the end of
the year well what we know at the moment
is a recession is predicted by the bank
of england and what we need to make sure
is we're using all the tools at our
disposal keeping taxes low doing the
reforms we need to to our economy to get
growth going faster to encourage people
to set up businesses to encourage
businesses to invest and i want us to be
on the side of people who work hard
people who do the right thing people who
support their families people who set up
businesses and that's why it's so
important we don't burden them with
excess regulation but that we also keep
taxes low under the current proposals
our corporation tax would go up to the
same level as france and 10 points ahead
of ireland and i really worry about our
capacity to attract that investment into
our economy if we do that you simply
can't tax your way to growth and i'm
afraid the very high taxes we have at
the moment a 70-year high are likely to
lead to a recession okay and that's what
the bank of england is predicting okay
neha is here neha good evening t what's
your question for mistrust uh hi liz my
question is i'm amongst very few in my
age group in ethnicity that are actually
members of the conservative party i've
been speaking to some of us and we are
afraid that the party has lost
credibility so my question is how will
you repair the damage to the party's
reputation well the most important thing
is we deliver on the promises we made we
got elected across the country in 2019
because of our manifesto we said we'd
unleash opportunity that we would
grow the economy that we would keep
taxes low so we need to deliver on all
of those things we need to deliver on
the opportunities of brexit and when we
promise something we need to follow
through on it i think that's really
important but i also want the
conservative party to be a party that
reaches out to everybody across the
country gets new people on board
encourages people to join our party
because we've got some fantastically
talented mps but we need a new
generation of members and i would
appoint a really strong party chairman
uh to encourage that to happen any clues
i i have not i am definitely okay not
being premature uh we're still in the
middle of a leadership race and what i'm
about is about talking to our party
members about my policies for government
but what i can say is i would always
make sure i appointed people to my
cabinet on the basis of merits and
people that get things done because what
people really want us to do is deliver
and we've only got two years it's not a
long amount of time and we need to get
started straight away so i want people
from all parts of the party from all
parts of the country who can really get
on and deliver okay politicians always
say that our party is a broad church and
i always point out to them that people
die in broad church
let's
[Laughter]
good evening liz
i'm a medical consultant
i work in a hospital
and i see day in day out the relentless
pressure that our medical staff is
having now understaffing is a real issue
at this moment in time if you become the
next prime minister how will you solve
this
well first of all the nhs has done a
fantastic job in covid but we are facing
a huge backlog and that is putting huge
pressure on first of all i make sure
we're putting the recent funding we
allocated the 13 billion into social
care because there are many people who
are in hospital who ought to be in
social care but there aren't the beds
available so i'd first of all make sure
we're investing the money in social care
i'd also support our doctors and nurses
more by removing some of the central
dictats and also having fewer layers of
management i've
on the campaign trail over the last few
weeks i've met people who face seven or
eight layers of management above them
and i think that can be quite difficult
and quite demotivating and what we need
is more of the
uh more of the empowerment more of the
decisions to be made by people on the
front line there are also a number of
other issues we need to look at like
doctors pensions i've met a lot of
doctors who've gone into retirement
because of the specific issues around
their pensions i need to sort that out
and also
there are many doctors who very kindly
came out of retirement to help during
covert you know help with the
vaccination program help with uh the
real issues we face in our hospitals and
what i'd like to do is see what we can
do to encourage those people to come
back into the profession and really help
because we do face serious issues it is
difficult to get a gp appointment i
represent a rural area we've got real
problems with ambulance waiting times as
well so we need all hands on deck but i
really believe that it's by trusting
people on the front line trusting the
professionals more and
making the organization a really great
place to work that we will actually
solve these problems together
i will say that i know that uh people
that i work with would be really really
happy if you looked into pension tax
because a lot of people are going into
early retirement exactly i'm sure that
will help bring the waiting list down
and uh um you know help the road for
recovery as well so thank you thank you
but but we also need to listen to people
like you who are actually involved in
the health service and listen to your
advice because what what i've heard
is lots of areas where we could use our
facilities better so for example i met a
doctor
who told me that he wanted to go in and
work at the weekend use the equipment of
the weekend but actually he'd been
banned from more senior people in the
organization from doing that so there
are things like that that i think we can
empower people to do things differently
and really treat this as a major
national program to to deal with the
aftermath of coping we were very
successful at dealing with covert
getting the vaccine rolling out the
vaccine but now we have a a major issue
with the national health service and we
need all of the best brains working on
it just clarify are you suggesting that
you should stack layers of management no
i'm not what i'm suggesting is that we
need to deploy people in the national
health service
better and what i have heard so i'll
keep them there's been a lot of there's
been a lot of targets set centrally by
the department of health and nhs england
and i want things to be decided more
locally so there's less
distance between the people making the
decisions and the people actually on
front line people want to ask you
questions mr i think david from guilford
david where are you hand up david
where is he there he is he's just here
david you've got a question on ukraine i
believe i have i thought it was going to
rishi i must admit oh well
i'm i'm perfectly happy
how would you propose to broker peace
negotiations in ukraine as opposed to
continuing to provide arms to prolong
the state of war
well the only way
this war will end is when the russians
leave ukraine and we need to make sure
that we
enable the ukrainians to defeat vladimir
putin if there's any
failed peace settlement if there's any
giveaway of ukrainian territory what we
know from history is russia will just
come back for more we saw that with the
minsk accords which didn't work and we
know what vladimir putin's plans are he
said that he wants to create a greater
russia essentially the old soviet union
including the likes of the baltic states
so that is why it's so important that we
were the first european country to
supply weapons to ukraine and we need to
continue to do that but we also need to
work with our allies like the americans
who are also putting weapons into
ukraine we also need to toughen up the
sanctions on russia because at the
moment the way putin is able to fund his
appalling war machine is because of the
oil and gas revenues that he's getting
and so that means us finding alternative
sources particularly in the uk we we
have the north sea we can invest in more
nuclear but it also involves other
countries finding alternative sources as
well because what putin has done is he's
used europe's dependence on russian gas
to hold the whole continent to ransom
and that is appalling and we know the
end result of what happens when
dictators get appeased is that every
inch of um territory that's been taken
since 2014 well i certainly think it
would be wrong for us to give away
any territory on behalf of the
ukrainians now of course president
zielenski
and it ultimately is the person who has
to determine what an eventual peace deal
would look like and he has been very
clear that russia needs to leave the
entirety of the ukrainian territory but
i think it'd be completely wrong for the
united kingdom or indeed any other
country to say
ukraine should give up part of that
their territory that would be very wrong
and what i worry
is the lesson it would give to
aggressors around the world
if russia was seen by saber rattling by
landing up lining up troops on the
border lining up tanks from the border
then successfully gaining a piece of
ukrainian territory what message would
that send to others around the world it
would be a terrible message and the
long-term threat to global security
would be appalling david no i just
wondered if you you didn't mention
anything uh about attempting to
negotiate or broker some peace deal
we have been involved in working on
negotiations with our american french
and german colleagues and we are
providing support to the ukrainians to
do just that but it is ultimately about
what the ukrainians are willing to
negotiate what i don't want to see is
ukraine be put under any pressure
to give up territory for expediency's
sake because i'm saying it simply won't
be expedient because all we'll see
is russia retreat and then come back for
more later and they still haven't given
up their ambitions to take the whole of
ukraine it was a tactical retreat away
from kiev not a long-term retreat and we
need to be very very worried about
putin's intentions it's one of the
reasons by the way that i favor raising
our defense spending to three percent of
gdp over the next year we've got lots of
questions to get through so
not at all i want to bring in our next
question which is about housing and it's
from jude from chippenham and i've
wanted to say this all evening hey jude
okay thank you very much
um hello foreign secretary i've recently
graduated and will be moving to london
to start a new job as a commercial
lawyer
when i made the decision i thought
perhaps naively that it would make sense
to buy somewhere in london rather than
rent
but that was before i saw the cost of a
deposit on a starter home
how will you
solve the housing crisis and make it
easier for young people to own their own
home
jude i think it's incredibly important
that we help more people get on the
housing ladder it is a problem that this
generation of young people
end up buying houses much later in their
lives than previous generations
but the way to do it is not the system
we have at the moment which is
soviet-style top-down housing targets
which simply
uh cause huge concern and don't actually
deliver the results we want and i've
before i became an mp i was a counsellor
i sat on a planning committee it was
hours of my life i'll never get back
because because
we didn't have any control over what
happened everything got overruled by the
planning and spectra in bristol so what
i want is a much more localized system
of planning so in london for example i
think there's more opportunity to build
up
in london
to build more you know higher story
buildings i think in other parts of the
country what we need is more
investment zones where we have
industry developed alongside homes
alongside infrastructure and that can be
determined by local people but the
one-size-fits-all planning system we
have at the moment simply doesn't work
the other thing i do to help you
specifically
is when somebody does rent they should
be able to use their rental history
towards getting a mortgage for their
home and that will help people who are
long-term rental renters get onto the
housing ladder okay just want to share
this quote with you
that you i think it was three years ago
perhaps a little bit longer we need to
build a million homes on the london
green belt near railway stations and
around other growing cities specifically
to allow the under 40s to be able to own
their own homes do you still want to
build a million homes on green belts and
the like so what i don't want to do kay
is build it on the green belt
because i do think well i've changed
i've changed my view on that i'm still
very keen for the under 40s to be able
to aim their own homes but what i've
seen
is that the way these top-down targets
have resulted in having the opposite
effect of getting the homes built and
i'm now of the view that what we need to
do is have incentives
to get local councils to set up
investment zones and do things
differently because the current system
isn't working okay so you've changed
your mind on that one uh jill from
tunbridge wells are you angry jill
just about disgusted
hi liz hi
how important is it to balance the books
so the answer is it is important over
the long term to make sure that the
private sector is growing faster than
the public sector and we were able to
generate the revenues for our economy
and also be able to pay for our public
services but it isn't right to try and
balance the book straight away when
we've had a major global crisis like
covid and every single country in the
world has built up debts from that
crisis and in fact we have lower levels
of debt than most of the g7 countries so
i think trying to balance the books
prematurely is actually
counterproductive because if you put up
taxes and you stop businesses forming
you stop new investment and you stop
economic growth you're less likely to be
able to pay down the debt over the
longer term
happy with that no it doesn't look as
though you're not so what's your
follow-up question on that one liz i do
not want to see my children
and my grandchildren encumbered with
huge debt at a time of rising interest
rates bank of england today and at a
time of high inflation the one thing
margaret thatcher believed in was sound
money this is not sound economics and
the whole business about economic growth
tax cuts do not necessarily produce
economic growth if you look at germany
for example it has much higher
corporation tax than we have and indeed
even with the rises that are in the
pipeline and yet their economy is not
tanking in the way that ours is tanking
so i think this is this question of
balancing the books is really
fundamental signed by sources and
economics well
we we have lower levels of debt
than countries like the us
canada and japan so it's simply not true
to say that we have particularly high
national debt at the moment but what i
do know
is that families across the country are
struggling to pay their bills and what i
would do is help release we sent
interest rates liz i remember those days
i had to pay a mortgage of 15 are we
going back to that level again no
because we've got an independent bank of
england that make decisions about
interest rates and we're that we're
we're nowhere near uh that's that
position at all
but to say
that we're going to put up taxes to the
highest level and beyond the highest
level in 70 years and we think there
will be no consequences for economic
growth i'm afraid i think that's wrong
and i speak to lots of companies lots of
businesses who are very concerned about
the proposals to raise corporation tax
they're very concerned about the level
of interest rates they're very concerned
about the regulations on their
businesses at the moment the fact is
that britain has got less competitive
relative to other countries under these
corporation tax proposals we would have
corporation tax that is 10 points higher
than ireland yeah and it will make us
less competitive germany and you don't
get germany well germany has a very very
different economic system from the uk
okay we've got one time for one more
question tom from gate said where's
charm we'll come back to the quest tom
hi sorry hi thanks very much liz why did
you announce a well-researched and fully
costed policy in which you openly said
you valued the work of teachers nurses
and police officers in newcastle where i
work
less than you value those in guilford
for example
we're having this election because of
poor judgment and trust
why should we trust your judgment
well the reason that i
immediately
decided not to pursue that policy
is it was being misinterpreted in fact
in exactly the way you said
because it wasn't about teachers or
nurses or doctors and
immediately as there were concerns
expressed about this policy
i said we're not going ahead with it and
i do think in politics there are times
when you have to
make judgments about what is right and
you have to be honest with the public
and i was very honest about the
situation it wasn't a core part of my
policy plan but i'd rather be up front
and if there's a problem make a decision
and deal it with it straight away and i
think you can see in my time as foreign
secretary in my time as trade secretary
i've been completely upfront about
everything i've done i've explained why
i've done it i've explained when there
is a change why there is a change and
that's the approach i would take as
prime minister
so that the press release didn't say
that it said that it would be um it in
order to reach the 8.8 billion in
savings that it would be expanded out
beyond civil service uh beyond the civil
service itself um so that's a mistake
will you apologize because it was
actually quite offensive
well i have been very clear
that i will not go ahead with this
policy
and that i have made a decision to do
that straight away and i've been upfront
about that i don't think there is
anything to be ashamed of of saying
publicly that
this is not working as i wanted it to
work and therefore i have changed the
position on it and i'm not going ahead
with it okay this gentleman had a view
on that just wait for a microphone so
can we just get a microphone down here
thank you you were shaking your head sir
i did yeah i hate this um
apologize you know for
everything that you might have said i
just don't really don't understand it
the the oppositional was asking uh other
politicians to apologize for what they
may or may not have done
uh and it really doesn't sit well with
me when somebody's asking for your vote
you don't expect to be offended
well
simply what's that supposed to mean well
good night
we are going into very very difficult
times as a country yeah and we've just
talked about that
and we need somebody leading this
country who is prepared to make
decisions who is prepared to
deal with issues as they arise and is
prepared to be up front with the public
okay i think i've demonstrated that in
everything i've done in all of the jobs
i've held okay during this campaign okay